Oh Jackson Jr kicks off our number
through inaudible throughout the rest of
the last hour and bits because we're
where our cup runneth over with
Jackson's or cubes or however you want
to put it oh she Jackson jr. Godzilla
king of the monsters is in a theater
near you
a week from Friday good to see you sir
glad I'm back that was a lot of fun and
and again it's one of those moments is a
host of a show or like okay O'Shea's
ready if you want to bring him out yeah
and his dad can stay till the end of the
hour cube could stay the end of the hour
and plus I just know you you were ready
you didn't have to have all that makeup
on you just roll out of bed looking this
way I'll hear what Kobe Bryant teaches
us yes is to always be prepared no
matter what just throw me the ball and
see what I do with it it's in and and
what you do is you win that's right
without my mentality I mom which is why
you're successful as you are obviously
or while you're wearing Laker shoes
right now these are these are my
Vegeta's these are my dragon ball zzzz
okay I'm always wearing my Laker heart
but that's like those aren't Laker
colors I don't know
oh that's blue I see it's not those are
Rams those are Rams colors that's right
that's true you know Todd Gurley the
dirty 30 I hope you're all right man
because we need you what Jason can you
get ready our our our the way that we've
been getting into this story the last
couple days courtesy of Steven ace Smith
please if you don't mind because it not
only applies to what's going on with
your Lakers team it also applause as to
what was going on with Todd Gurley at
the end of last season go for it here no
I mean that's what he started his
conversation with magic the other day
and that's is fully a pro that's the way
storm from Hollis Queens starts a
conversation yeah I feel so what what
what's going on with your Lakers let's
start with no and first off Oh shame uh
I just want to start off the interview
by saying go Lakers you know you're
looking at a true homegrown fan from the
forum you know it's hard to find this
now ok these days yes and we gonna be
alright and I love that the league
doesn't think so I'm glad that
everybody's getting their shine all you
single-digit championship teams throwing
your parades get your shirts get your
hats you know it'll be time it's time
for the King to return
just LeBron will talk about the Lakers
the logo 16-time the most winning
franchise in the league will be back the
logos in Los Angeles all right O'Shea we
all go through phases rich also in
Staples just you know for the Clippers
look no matter what a Clippers success
or their failure they tried to they try
to connect it to the Lakers somehow you
guys have bobblehead night and you have
a former Laker in a suit for your
bobblehead they have Jerry West for
bobblehead night you got to use the
Lakers no matter how you get to it
that's what the Clippers do you know
they got a they got a leach off us it's
fine I get it we're great but take it to
Seattle like what do you take them see
they can move them to Fort Lauderdale I
just you know it just really doesn't
matter I just feel like they're always
trying to divide our city no matter what
sport you look into except Kings go
Kings go and go sparks go okay but you
know no matter if y'all win a
championship yes or two yes or three or
four this is a Laker town it irks them
it gets to them it gets under their skin
and I love that go let me take this one
at a time here I know you're big fan and
all Clippers are moving Inglewood though
which is where you grew up watching the
Lakers to begin with yeah
once again elites off of it I understand
love it I understand the Clippers have a
playoff team that's currently continent
that took that took two off of the
defending world champs that the Blazers
couldn't do and that the Rockets only
were able to match mmm they also have a
max contract available for somebody that
might be playing in Game five tonight
the Toronto Raptors uniform potentially
or somebody who is waiting to come back
from a calf injury to play in Game one
of the NBA Finals potentially it doesn't
faze me man I'm trying to faze you I'm
trying to actually you know you know
Hawk reality I love the players yeah
hate the fans respectability
because he's been there from the jump
respect for this bandwagon jumpers push
where were they before what you talking
about yes of course I'm glad that y'all
make the playoffs in and shoe champagne
for making it into the playoffs and all
of that that's that's great you know I I
can't even remember when the Lakers used
to do that because we've been winning
before I can even like be thought of you
know and it's it's alright it's alright
to celebrate success but you know we're
the Lakers our success ends usually ends
with a rain we won't we won't be as
happy as they are to make things like
the playoffs and you know we Laker fans
have a saying if the Lakers can't win at
least the Clippers go and lose O'Shea
Jackson jr. here on the Richardson show
you are you're living in a glass house
you're stone throwing right now look for
a glass house right yes I mean when they
catch up when they get this double-digit
championship maybe but this sounds like
me with a Yankee fan in a Red Sox fan
there where you you want to talk a
little bit more recently you're not your
are you in all seriousness yeah you are
not concerned with what is which
transpired over the last four weeks
since the minute Magic Johnson held his
press conference on the last night of
the season in Staples hmm you are not
cannot concerned about this the
direction of this franchise right now
I'm not concerned I'm frustrated I'm for
sure frustrated you know there's a
couple of there's a couple of things
that are happening in the front office
that are frustrating you know there
shouldn't be between magic and Rob magic
shouldn't be the one that has to leave
and step down and do all that I get he
has other ventures and all that stuff
but I just feel that once our problems
in the front office are taken care of
once there they've gotten rid of all the
cooks that are in that kitchen and you
know let it be one then yeah we'll be
able to move forward but when I look at
my position I got three young horses for
four if you count to Josh the Hitman
Hart then we got the number four pick
with LeBron James and in cap space I
just don't
I'm not worried like everybody you know
wants me to be a wife I do like their
roster yeah it just seems so ill-fitting
based on some of the players that they
put around I'm not signing Brook Lopez
is something
that magic took took the hit for on
first take earlier this week but I'm
understand confused why you're such a
Kobe fan clearly yeah and you have the
Mamba mentality well I can't palinka
have that since that's that's Kobe's guy
because that's what that's what that
that's cope that's what who clearly
Jeanie buss is listening to as this
should be my guy because he's Kobe's guy
I'm assuming that's the triangle right
here if Kobe wanted to be in the front
office Kobe would be in the front office
just because you're my agent you're not
I'm not gonna include you as an
extension to me right now the way that
the picture is being painted it's making
its make it Rob Lincoln look a little
like little finger you know he's looking
a little petyr baelish and you know that
we don't we don't need any conspiracies
within the Laker brand well they're
already the best soap opera on TV let's
continue with this Chris Brockman was uh
we were talking about this O'Shea
Jackson jr. here in the Rich Eisen show
a signing Game of Thrones characters to
the current politics going down the
street going on down the street or El
Segundo clearly clearly Genii buses
Khaleesi franca okay that's who Kobe
told her to be when she was going
through her family that workout I know
we were asking who's the dragon that can
come and melt magic statue out in front
if he is the issue Kobe was that so out
of control then you certainly won't like
this one oh great you know magic is no
Jon Snow because because hold Armand
because he's the one that keeps telling
genie until want it clean don't want it
he's the one who keeps telling genie
you're my queen as he sticks the knife
in which which on Monday of all the days
for him to go on first take I know that
these things were were separate in the
same way that you and your dad showed up
separate today that was not planned
whatsoever happen exactly but if if you
promoting Godzilla would in any way
shape or form damage the big three mmm
wouldn't you call up and say let's do it
a different day that's what I'm saying
by magic here like he's Jon Snow like oh
you're my queen you're my queen you're
my queen but
I mean that's pretty good but oh yeah in
this world this world yeah I would say
that roppa League is a little finger I
would by the way Rob still here so it
cancels out my I'm sorry don't count the
Lakers will be all Ryan I know you guys
I know I know especially you
I know y'all waiting for us to fall and
y'all are doing over there in the East
without LeBron nuttin
that's cool I mean we'll be alright as
long as y'all don't win if we win I'm
good not doing any winning either look
man all right we'll stay at the house
with me then chill out
know what the best part about Godzilla
king of the monsters what is it we
destroy Boston in the movie I love it
it's so many references so liquor fans
dream Godzilla king of the monsters
gosh Dodger fans too cuz obviously the
Celtics tended yeah and the Rams
latest Lakers a golden dragon did you so
did you change this did you go to the
screenwriter and director and say my all
the only way I'm doing this film is if
you change the city if it gets destroyed
to Boston that was just you know just
the by the old gods in the new that was
just luck
knows God is a Laker fan so like oh we
have just destroyed Boston is destroyed
Ghidorah levels Boston the golden Hall
thank your dragon word Oh three-headed
monster big three gosh check it out
alright so the king of the monsters
right is we saw clip we saw clip yeah
and we asked for get another clip from
there for me filmmakers cuz you didn't
say much in this clip right you saw
those hands well yet you backed up it
was you you toss acting you talked with
your body but it's not subtle acting
that's the next level acting O'Shea
Jackson jr. Johnson show but it looks
like what people should expect from this
series correct yes and you know the
reason why we didn't have the clip is
because my character yes no Chief
Warrant Officer Barnes
he is a part of the military branch of
Monarch known as G team and you know
when I'm around it's usually the Titans
are around I'm usually in the worst
position possible you know being a
soldier and the gods of the movies got
to be like this is it he's about to die
and so it's you know it's a couple of
Easter eggs and spoilers and so most of
my scenes okay very good and we're
showing right now the this still of you
back and see those hands are you mean a
ball coach that's method actor yeah you
want the ball you're spotting up for
three or wide-open you're like you hear
me you're hit you hit me and then the
cast as well we're speaking of Thrones
Charles dance who plays Tywin Lannister
why did you pick his brain about any
Game of Thrones I mean not in we not in
no scene you know no scenes together no
I didn't see him at the premiere Warner
Brothers haha I see him there all right
Bradley Whitford Vera Farmiga Kyle
Chandler coach for how Chandler
yeah coach from yeah yeah super dope and
you know when I first got there I didn't
know that his accent was like for real
so I was like wow this dude's in
character
you know he's really like milking that
accent but they're like no that's Kyle
you know he's got the hair streamer on
the back of the truck like he is a he
likes to sleep under the stars type type
of guy and you know I know him from the
Peter Jackson King Kong it was like oh
my god Godzilla's the dude from King
Kong and they're like we're look he's
sneak dissing and so you know I loved it
I love these super dope guy and it's
merely Bobby Brown's
debut correct is young legend rreow yeah
milli Bobby holds it down in this film
okay I call him le ba because it sounds
like Ricky Bobby so like I called her
aria yes are you okay she's holding us
down
who's the Aria in the Lakers situation
oh there that's gonna be the free agent
the young person who goes West's of
Westeros there's nobody knows what's
over there
well nobody does know it's over yes
right yeah that's right who's the far
ball fan is my favorite Laker delusional
Laker friend is my favorite what are you
guys called you Celtics you guys still
think y'all gonna win over there with
Yanis and Kawhi and stuff that's not a
localized leavin Kai's not good B we
don't know great guess what we did
without him we were four minutes from
the last year we were how you were what
last year four minutes from the finals
without him four minutes from the fine
you know what I'm like a book good look
um
O'Shea I'm here for your Boston hate I'm
here for it oh okay speaking of somebody
who's from New York City a die-hard
Yankee fan I would take it in liquid
form and inject it into my veins I would
do that that's what's up okay and I say
this is you know my wife again uh you
were on her pot a couple times she's
from the Boston area
okay I've married into a Boston family
they're fully aware how I feel about
you're so strong I appreciate that but
you really don't have much of a position
right now to carp on a Celtic fan as a
Laker fan you just really are you don't
know no I know but you don't have like
you're out of position under the board's
right now you're you're reaching in
you're going over the top I'm caught I'm
like kind of calling the foul right now
and I'm sorry that's just you don't have
much listen I am a los Angelino I'm a
Los Angeles Laker a non Laker fan will
never see me sweat I will die with the
Golden Army they will bury me a centered
court and I will not let a Bostonian get
under my skin
he doesn't even want to be here that's
not true there's just no movies anywhere
else to be Warner Brothers film you're
in Space Jam right - I'm not a Space Jam
non Laker fans like you got my joke
wrong on Twitter
I missed the radio show and said that I
was resting a groin injury so I could
prepare to film Space Jam - which is
exactly what LeBron did for most of the
games so it was a joke that non Laker
fans didn't get put
on IMDB and they just spread out but
Warner Brothers I will take any job in
Space Jam 10 Space Jam to accept like so
I'm from Boston or anything so basically
for anybody out there
yeah O'Shea Jackson jr. currently not in
Space Jam 2 was just otherwise was just
making a load management joke which by
the way
not many people make load management
jokes in this level I appreciate that I
don't like saying load management and
growing injury I don't say started that
I think you could take a pill furloughed
man you'd have to be in a bathtub no
just sign you need a little bit more
brand in your diet or take a pill for
load management problems Brandon Stark
sucks so I brandstar who was Brian in
the Lakers situation
who is the new whoever the new owner
would be magic is like three different
characters yeah right this whole thing
what a guy levar levar bran is Jerry
West how about that Jerry West just
sitting back knowing it's all gonna come
back on his lap bran start come back
it's all gonna come back to him now
brand bran was gym bus who did nothing
to be the king levar is Varys right
right whispering Loki whispers little
birds and then LeBron came in and just
tricked or caressed him out of the
pictures LeBron who is LeBron well if
it's courting you if somebody doesn't
want to be in Westeros anymore so maybe
that's Arya out right please that's the
what's west of Westeros nobody knows is
where the map stops the rest know where
the restaurants still in that the king
of the monsters Godzilla king of the
monsters is in theaters near you Friday
May 31st the man who plays the role of
Jackson Barnes and it's amazing he plays
himself in this movie a guy who's
totally delusional about his favorite
basketball team
you know already strange I just want to
say go Lakers
and nobody else when are you coming back
on O'Shea man way too long
you see whatever but you're too busy
that's not true your career the house
the Lakers are not good we still the
worst Laker franchise is better than the
best of anything else okay Jackson jr. I
left you man's I'll see you at Staples
okay
O'Shea Jackson jr. on both Twitter and
Instagram for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on VR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app